it's show time with Germany's craziest
advertising duo there's a pop star
quality to helmet wearing dr. Gaylord
Robertson or rocket and Petronius Armand
wink clad in Jude headwear amid much
excitement they're presenting their
latest campaign at a venue in Hamburg
Rakatan wink don't talk on camera but
rely on Gary unclogged to be there
humorous mouthpiece but there's no point
in asking about their costumes what
costumes more serious answers are
occasionally forthcoming me pop logic is
on music is a constant in the lives of
rocket and wink and that is a fact its
bets on music is a source of inspiration
for rocket and wink on Rakatan pink
UNAMID emas ekan on the whole they work
together but in their project rocket
versus wink they are opponents their
creative graphic dual has been going on
for weeks rocket is red wing is blue
they present the results in their
graphic magazine whatever
visitors to the show experienced the
final of the jewel as a live battle the
disciplines include whipping cream
playing chess and tearing up telephone
books in what amounts to an entertaining
art performance by two advertising
professionals
graphic design without rules sure
they're silly but I still like it the
pictures are strange and so is
everything about them the concept works
it's about communication right so it's
about making a brand so they make up
made a brand for themselves they've been
going for three or four years and
they're always doing cool new things
standish invention or influenza rocket
and wink have worked on around 90
project since 2011 including a nike
campaign featuring german soccer star
measured ouzel last year they design
posters for a series of concerts for a
herbal after-dinner drink manufacturer
numerous German musicians turn to them
for their artwork rocket and wink our
designers illustrators product
developers and artists who regard
themselves as a think tank they have
reached the point where they can choose
their own clients a rock and pick up
rocket and wink have turned jobs down
because they get requests to do things
they can't do or don't want to do turn
on your phone violence until three years
ago they both worked in major
advertising agencies they only employed
to permanent members of staff in their
little office but that doesn't stop them
winning awards the rocket and wink style
seems to have an international appeal
Heinrich para vicini co-owns the Hamburg
advertising agency mutter bore and his
head of design at the German art
directors club which recently gave
rocket and wink and award for its
campaign for a German newspaper buses
are companies were also given each
Marcus what makes this campaign so
unusual is that we can determine how a
major and rather traditional media
organization like exodia is willing to
go for a campaign that uses street art
and combines a sprayed look with the
rough and the broken
that's very unusual that's how I transia
I also give early every two months
rocket and wink changed this billboard
the drinks manufacturer now on show is
one of the agency's most loyal clients
many Fritz Kohler adverts have a vintage
look they are both minimalistic and
classic
what is the US Fish pizza I would
describe them as the figureheads of a
movement we're experiencing a kind of
Renaissance of graphic artists in the
graphic design world and it's been a
major topic in Germany my two of them
pull it off perfectly Biden they love
the craft although one is more
traditional and the other is seen as
modern but they love making a craft out
of it out of using their hands I'm Vicki
Anderson how apt then that they should
end their duel with a tug of war
although rocket falls on the floor the
undisputed champion of the evening is
creativity